Someone said this,
I think it was Terence Mckenna,
that people have a problem with something that's real that you can't hit with a
hammer.
Right.
And I think that's a real way of putting it.
It's a real interesting because farts are real as fuck dude,
and you can't wrap your hands around them,
but you know they're real.
Sound is real.
But we accept it because we're so used to it.
The idea of this invisible thing can,
can transmit music and harmony and beautiful feelings and make you fucking
pumped up and you hear it in your car singing it.
What?
What the what the fuck is that?
It's invisible shit and invisible.
Shitty,
but it's coming for fucking satellites down.
We want to think that we've got the whole world figured out who want to think
that we know what's real and what's here and that all the weakened sense is all
it is there.
And I say,
fuck that.
I said,
that's sure
did us,
dude,
we are weird.
We're weird.
And we don't realize how weird we are.
Like while we're being weird,
we don't realize it.
[inaudible] you got to work on this life to make money,
but the fuck is money.
Who are you?
What is this?
What are we doing here?
And if you look at the resources that you have available to you being 24 hours
in a day and a certain amount of your health,
I think about what you dedicate most of that resources too.
And what's your reward on that?
Well,
you got a house,
you got a box where you can fucking pass out every night in front of the
television.
Is that what you're doing?
The idea that you need to do anything stupid and people just always telling me
that you're like,
oh,
you need to grow up.
You need to grow up.
What do you what to do?
What to die,
Dwight,
to fall into line,
to fucking follow a pattern.
You don't need to do anything.
Nobody was doing anything.
You need to breathe,
you need to eat food.
The rest of his is the structure that we've sort of invented to sort of give
ourselves something to do.
When we wake up in the morning,
well,
it's nine.
I am trying to go to work.
Work's not real.
The car's not real life,
not real.
This is what's real heartbeats.
And when those bitches stop,
all that shit that you created and stockpiled and worked for means not nothing.
These objects that didn't even exist when you're dead,
when you're dead,
you're going to go to another dimension where you can't take this shit with you,
you know,
or not,
or delights you.
Shut off.
Life is about us interacting with each other and if you can contribute in any
way,
there's a lot of people that are great parents that contribute to this world by
being a great parent,
by raising someone who's going to influence other people,
and a lot of them don't necessarily get too much credit for that.
That's an incredible resource.
And the idea that every one of them is just fucking up the world.
Whatever the world's fucked period.
It's we're,
we're,
we're 2014 all right.
The direction that we're going in is fucked.
It's all fucked was too many of us.
There's too much pollution.
It's not changing.
There's no,
there's the,
the global warming is happening whether you like it or not,
whether you blame it on democratic Vaginas,
sponsors,
whatever,
the,
whatever you do doesn't matter.
Yeah.
Blue Live,
just live,
be alive.
I could just see that and being cut into one of those youtube videos.
That's somebody who isn't in the background.
There's like people walking fast than the sun rising really slow.